well recipe for a happy life research is
showing according to this Edline less
materialism more gratitude new research
finds materialistic people are less
happy in large part because of their
lack of gratitude picture the most
materialistic people you know they don't
seem to be very happy do they they
certainly have more stuff than most of
us and we're constantly bombarded with
messages that equates stuff with bliss
so what's missing from their lives well
a newly published new newly published
research suggests a clear answer
gratitude
hi materialists are less happy in part
because they find it harder to be
grateful for what they have the
researchers argue that because of this
low level of gratitude basic
psychological needs which allow
individuals to thrive go largely unmet
as in past research we found that
materialism was negatively associated
with well-being the researchers right
then breaking new ground they add that
their results suggest one major reason
for this is likely the decreased
gratitude that materialists experienced
the resultant decreases in basic
psychological needs there are several
theories regarding why materialistic
people feel less gratitude as research
as the researchers note it only makes
sense that a materialistic outlook which
looks for satisfaction in what one does
not have would impair the ability to be
grateful for what one has now such
people can get caught in a negative
spiral in which they have an unrealistic
expectations of how happy material goods
will make them when their experience
falls short of those expectations their
instinct is to seek out something new to
purchase putting them in an endless loop
of anticipation and disappointment that
does not leave room for gratitude
very interesting sometimes some of you
get confused about materialism what it
is materialism is a it's a form of
religion
it is a where you are worshipping
something and materialism is the worship
of stuff it is not the acquisition of
stuff and it's not the a certain level
of ownership of stuff you can actually
not have any stuff and still be very
materialistic you can not have to have
many materials and be very materialistic
because it's all about what you worship
it's all about what you think is going
to make you happy so I think if I get a
new car I'll be happy then I think if I
get a new house I'll be happy then I
think if I go on vacation I'll be happy
then I think if I that's a materialist
that's someone who is constantly
searching for fulfilment or happiness or
wholeness through the ownership or
purchase or acquisition of stuff we call
it stuff itis it's a disease and we all
have a little bit of it it's like you
know you ever thought if I could just
get a decent dadgum car I mean I drove
junk freakin cars for so long they were
just beat up old bondo buggies that I
thought was going to leave me dead on
the side of the road at any minute I
drove that stuff for so long and I
always I have to admit I just would
think if I could just get a decent car
that's a form of materialism that our
stuff itis that I was suffering from now
I will tell you and I don't want you to
get materialism confused with stuff
because again stuff is not evil getting
a large pile of stuff is not evil it
just messes you up when you think that's
going to make you happy because I'll
tell you if you eat enough Lobster it
tastes like soap there's no there's no
going out to dinner that's ever going to
be good enough
and then you can't get satiated with
there's no purchase of clothing or
purchase of an item you collect or you
know whatever the thing is that doesn't
do that so again just to reiterate I
know wealthy people who have a lot of
things who are not materialistic think
about it because materialistic is not
about the amount of stuff it's about the
view of stuff you can be poor and be
materialistic you can be rich and be
materialistic the saddest ones
are the wealthy that are materialistic
that's very sad because the it's like it
was like a dog chasing a car they
finally caught it they don't know what
to do with it there's no satisfaction
now what do I do
I caught it I can't I don't I don't know
how to drive a car that's what the dog
says right just you know you know we got
leash laws everywhere now most of you
ending grown up seen a dog chasing the
car but I was growing up the dogs all
ran loose and they all chase cars not
all of them but the dumb ones did a lot
of three legged ones did from where they
got hit by the car but what do you do if
your dog chasing a car when you catch it
what do you do if your material is when
you finally get a pile of stuff does it
really fill up that hole in your soul no
it did not
that's materialism and materialism is
not related to the amount of stuff that
someone has but very interesting they
have a low level of gratitude a low
level of gratitude they have a sense of
entitlement
yeah entitlement is opposite of
gratitude one of the opposites
interesting and you know some of the
ugliest people on the planet are those
that are ungrateful you ever done
something for somebody and you thought
you did a really good day and they just
look at you just completely ungrateful
just a sense of arrogant entitlement
that's an ugly ugly thing for you or
your kid to have it's an ugly character
trait it's the people you want to help
the least mind tweeted he's ladies
coming down the aisle in the airplane
and he jumps up out of his seat and
helps her put her but she's struggling
with her buddy helps her put her bag up
overhead um and she doesn't say thank
you she doesn't say anything
her answer was you can help me get it
down when we leave
that's her answer it's just you makes
you want to take it back out the
overhead and sit it in the aisle for ya
yeah
you pilot test pilot for a broom Factory
seriously you should set that ungrateful
it's it's ugly lack of gratitude is ugly
and there there is a huge correlation
between happiness and gratitude and by
the way gratitude is a decision just
like materialism is a decision you get
to decide to be grateful you can just
look at the sunrise in the morning look
at the sunset in the evening you can
look at the life that you have and say
I'm working on making it better but I am
grateful for where I am gratitude is not
mean you're not ambitious does not mean
you're not go Laurie in it just means
you smile and nod and tip your hat and
say thank you thank you God
thank you God thank you to your wife
thank you to your kids thank you to the
guy who put your bag in the overhead
compartment it's a grant and a thank you
it's a spirit of gratitude it's very
appealing and it's the opposite of
entitlement the opposite of materialism
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you
you